so you're the man with the answers is
there going to be an election I hope not
I don't think an election would solve
anything because the that the time is of
the essence we've got breasts to deliver
we don't want to add any more
unnecessary delay there's been too much
of that already we need to focus on
delivering brexit so we can get on with
delivering good government for the
British people and the general election
would only delay that the outcome would
be uncertain so none of the none of the
things that people tell us they want
which is brexit delivered and some
certainty for both themselves businesses
none of those things would be helped
with the general election I mean the
thing is some people argue that actually
the only way to deliver brexit is to get
a new Parliament I mean we can look at
what Theresa May herself said on Friday
she said I fear that we are reaching the
limits of this process in this house I
mean that sounds like a pretty little
hint doesn't it that she's so first-rate
- that the MPs in this house aren't
gonna be able to come - yeah I mean you
can read a lot of things into that I my
interpretation of what she meant from
that I'm not discussing with her
directly but my interpretation of what
she meant from that is that is that the
April 12th deadline is pretty much upon
us the house said the House of Commons
said it wanted to take control it wanted
to be the decision-making body it wanted
to come up with the future options and
so the indicative vote process was
enable was to enable the house to do
that and then what the house
spectacularly failed to do was come up
with anything so all the various options
that were put before us were all voted
down I think what the Prime Minister was
saying there is that this is time to
time to focus time to grow up time to
get real we've got to deliver brexit
there is a way of doing that that signed
off by the EU
it is deliverable it does work it's the
withdrawal agreement that's what we
should focus on so are you preparing for
general election
we're not planning for a general
election the the Conservative Party
papel be completely straight with you we
have got a we've got a minority
government in a turbulent time so we you
know just in terms of sensible pragmatic
planning but we are not seeking
preparing in in in that kind of
since that I think you mean for a
general election what the [ __ ] what the
government what the party what MPs are
focused on for the most part should be
focused on is delivering brexit because
without that all the other all the other
conversations that's displacement
activity that's belly button gazing
we've got the job of work to doing we
really should be doing it should Theresa
may lead you into the next election well
she said she did she said she doesn't
intend to he said she won't leave into a
2022 election she hasn't really been
that specific if there's a snap election
as you say there's a government it's
quite fragile situation so the
conservative leadership process takes a
period of time and again that process
introduces delay and uncertainty at
exactly the point in time when we need
neither the Prime Minister has been
consistent she's been can she's been
clear that her focus is on delivering
brexit there is the snap election if it
takes you by surprise and like you say
we're being realistic about a landslide
landscape to reason they could lead you
into that election that's what was that
well that's that's the that is the
inevitable possibility but and I wrote
about this in in the in expressed today
the British people keep telling me I was
in my constituency on Saturday before I
came back to London they are number of
people coming up to me just saying I'll
James please just get on with it and I
keep saying to them look we're trying I
promise you were trying and there's a
way of doing it and it's there it's on
the table and on the vote on Friday an
increasing number of MPs Conservative
MPs it been opposed to the withdrawal
agreement you said look you know what I
get it I get it
this really is the only way to get us
out the European Union so in that with
that in mind are you gonna be bringing
the vote back next week for another guy
I'm lucky I'm I'm not I'm not part of
that decision-making process - a party
position rather than the government
position but the simple truth of the
matter do you think name do you think it
should well and again I made this point
when I've spoken to people over the
weekend there are now a really limited
range of options April the 12th is a
point at which if we haven't agreed
anything else we leave without an
agreement without
deal or we sign off on an agreement and
that's the one that's in front of us or
we run the risk of brexit not happening
at all and I think that would be an
absolutely catastrophic failure be the
collapse in confidence from the British
electors the undermining of democracy I
think would be a catastrophic ly bad
move so for me I've always been willing
to accept leaving without a deal it's
not a preferred option even for me and
I'm staunch brexit ear so for me the
answer is really really simple is the
withdrawal agreement hey would you blame
you're talking then about how you think
it'd be catastrophic if murex it doesn't
happen
who would you blame I mean would you
blame fellow Brett suitors like yourself
in the Conservative Party who felt
unable to hold their noses and vote for
the withdrawal agreement well many
people who have that position have I've
changed their position not enough not
enough I would say this one I but the
people I am particularly frustrated with
are labour members of parliament because
they said over and over again that their
criticism of this was about the future
relationship the political declaration
they kept talking about they wanted the
customs union
Emily Phil Murray earlier on this
morning said that she wanted a customs
union you can't even have those
discussions you can't even start those
discussions until you formally sever the
relationship with the EU that is done
through the withdrawal agreement so
voting down the mechanism would need
Labour MPs that if you had enough
conservatives about the deal this is
true this is true and the Conservatives
who are opposing it I believe are
opposing it for passionately held and
honourable reasons and they have been
consistent I disagree in their
interpretation of this but they have
been consistent the people have been
really inconsistent are our members of
the Labour Party who have said publicly
they don't have a problem with the
withdrawal agreement their concern is
about the political declaration and the
future agreement and then when given the
opportunity to vote just on the
withdrawal agreement they made up some
hocus-pocus
excuse for not doing so and have failed
to deliver brexit those Labour MPs
despite what they promised failed to
deliver brexit and I think they should
be held accountable for okay now I'm
keen to talk to you about stop and
savage you know while we've got you on
the program
knife crime is something that is really
causing a lot of alarm around the
country at the minute and the Home
Secretary announcing that he's gonna be
relaxing police's powers to try and use
more stop and search I mean is that
something you welcome well the section
60 powers are an important part of the
arsenal of police powers when I was in
charge of the youth portfolio in City
Hall when I was on the London
Assemblymember we inherited a knife
crime academic from the former Labour
mayor of London and enhancing stop and
search was an important part but on its
own it's not enough you need to do that
you do need to do that in the moment to
reduce imminent risk but you also have
to work upstream this is what we did
when we were running London successfully
back when it have a decent there and we
used stop and sir or the police used
stop and search but there was also a
whole load of work about keeping people
young people out of trouble uniformed
youth groups for the police I mean we
know that black men for example nine
times more likely to be stopped and
searched for it on its own it can be but
as part of a wider package of
interventions it is a it is an important
part if it's used in exclusion to other
things it could be problematic but it
isn't so the the home office as well as
these stop and search powers are also
looking at making it harder for young
people to get hold of knives it's also
doing a whole load of work with other
government departments working quite
closely with communities local
government to make sure that there are
other diversionary activities it is part
an important part but only part of an
overall package of responses